Speaker 1: We're entering a sort of fascinating
and bizarre period of the Fox News defamation
text message scandal. And the latest player in
this insane theater act of sorts is Mark Levin.
Mark Levin is often framed as I'm the serious guy
on Fox News. I only do a weekly show because I'm
busy doing very serious things on all of my other
days. And you can count on me. Forget about what
happens on the weekdays or during the day, Sunday
night or wherever, wherever, whenever his show is,
you're really going to get serious stuff from me.
And so in the midst of this defamation lawsuit
from Dominion Voting Systems against Fox News and
the leaked text messages wherein we find out that
even though Tucker Carlson is pretending like he
might be a believer of the 2020 conspiracy theory
that Trump actually won behind the scenes, he's
texting, I hate Trump passionately, and this is
crazy. And our viewers don't know the difference.
And it's on that in the middle of all of that.
Mark Levin, without anyone forcing him
to do this, he tells us in the segment,
nobody told him to do this. He delivers
a cringeworthy and bizarre rant defending
Fox News. Okay. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 2: You know, it's a great honor
for me to come to you every Sunday night
on this network, the Fox News Channel.
And I want you to know something. Yeah, I
could not do this show anywhere else on cable,
on network TV and so forth, because.
Speaker 1: Is it that is it is that bad,
Mark? Is it such a bad show? No
one else would have it. Geez.
Speaker 2: Wouldn't allow it, I'm sure. So several
years ago, Fox, Mr. Murdoch and Suzanne Scott,
the CEO, asked me if I would do a show.
Speaker 1: And, you know, he's really
honest right now because he took off
his glasses to deliver part of this.
Speaker 2: They didn't even ask me what kind of
show. And I said, okay, let's do it. I'd like
to do it on a Sunday night late. I'd like to
see how we can do it. A long form interview,
do what you can and do the best you can. And
that's pretty much the only direction I've ever
been given. Wow. And so I tell you this for a
reason. When I come here and do this program,
I determine what I'm going to
say in the opening statement.
I determine who the guests are going to be.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that it's not that
when hosts say that it's not true, but
like it's meaningless in the sense that
the hosts at R.T. remember when Russian propaganda
TV was on in the United States, R.T. TV,
and a really long time ago I appeared
on it as well until I decided, like,
that's I'm never doing that again. It just it
doesn't doesn't mean it doesn't feel right to be
doing it. But 12 years ago, I appeared on there a
couple of times. The hosts there would always say,
No one ever told me what to say here. I decided
what to say. And as we previously analyzed. Yeah,
okay, that's that's fine. But what you have to
understand is they are screening for content by
who they hire. You're only there because they know
you're already going to say things that they're
okay with. So that phrase, a lot of these people,
when they work at a propaganda network, whether
it's R.T. or Fox News, they go, no one comes here
and tells me nobody writes my monologue for me
doesn't really mean that much.
Speaker 2: They have enough faith in me to
know that I'm not going to blow the place up. Oh,
and this is very important to understand, because
they treat all the hosts this way. They treat
the newsroom this way and this fantastic network.
Speaker 1: Yeah, They don't
even care if the newsroom
lies. They let them do whatever they want.
Speaker 2: If it didn't exist, I want you
to think about what kind of media you would be
receiving day in and day out from Meet the Press,
from Good Morning America, from God knows.
Speaker 1: What. He's comparing different
types of programs in order to make everything else
seem consumed by trivialities. Now, of course,
there's plenty of triviality on Fox News as well.
Speaker 2: It would just be the same thing
over and over again. We really do
have a competition of ideas here,
even among conservatives, even within the
newsroom. And that's a good thing. That's
the way it's supposed to be. This is a
vibrant, vigorous network. Nobody asked
me to tell you this. I just decided to say it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, There's nobody just off screen
holding a gun pointing at me.
Speaker 2: Tell you why.
Even though we come under attack here, we come
under attack from the same sources who have lied
to you about so much and continue to lie to you
about so much. They're basically appendages of
the Democrat Party. They're mouthpieces for the
left. There's simply no question about that.
Speaker 1: Sounds pretty good. I mean, Fox News
sounds like a pretty great, great place. Right.
And remember, nobody told him to say this. So the
bottom line here is that you can come at this from
any angle you want and use this pathetic speech
to to enter this discussion anywhere you want to
enter it. Fox News has admitted in court and under
oath that they lie in the sense that when are
people like Tucker Carlson or whoever say things,
it should be understood that they are being
entertaining and using hyperbole and exaggeration
for the sake of entertainment. Not these are news
people delivering the most accurate version of
the facts that they are able to find. And you
then work backwards from there and you get to the
defamation suit, which is partially the result of
entertainers making the ratings based decision,
even when they didn't believe a lot of this stuff
privately to allow conspiracy theories on air,
which allegedly bordered over into defamation as
far as Dominion voting systems was concerned. Now,
we know that there seem to be some true believers
at Fox News. For example, last week we looked at
text messages between Fox host Maria BARTIROMO
and Stephen Bannon. In those texts, it really
seemed like Maria BARTIROMO was a true believer.
But Tucker was not. Laura Ingraham was not. Sean
HANNITY was not, at least from the texts that
were revealed. Whether that makes Fox great or
whether that makes Fox bad or not news or news or
whatever, well, those are all different questions.
But these sorts of speeches delusionally defending
Fox News as the last bastion of people being able
to learn about the world around them. Not only is
it pathetic and unhinged, I don't even think
Mark Levin believes it. To be perfectly frank,